it's time for the lawn gene prana scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope Larry lisseur from the
CBS television news staff and or is
texture chief editorial writer for The
New York Herald Tribune our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the honorable Homer k part united states
senator from Indiana a couple of months
have passed since the Federal Housing
Administration slipped and fell into a
sticky morass of scandal nearly ten
years we're told sharp operators have
made windfall profits out of various FHA
projects now our guest tonight as
chairman of the senate banking and
finance committee is investigating the
scandal so we'd like to ask senator kay
part said since some prominent names
have been mentioned in this mess both
builders and their backers all these
people actually guilty of violating the
law and well i don't know that i should
answer that question there because we're
investigating at the moment and i'm
chairman of the committee i always try
to be fair and honest with these people
and I don't think I should prejudge them
however I will say this that it it looks
as though at the moment there's been a
lot of irregularities it looks as though
there has been a lot of miss their
maladministration on the part of those
administering the law laws in the past
and that's been very loosely handled
whether there will be violations remains
of course for the courts to decide well
will you pass this on to the Department
of Justice your findings oh yes of
course and the Department of Justice of
course have someone sitting there each
day at our earrings so the K part when
do these hearings begin they began they
be on monday this week and how
I continue to expect why suspect is
going to take the biggest part of this
year I doubt very much if we finish
before december well senator do you
think this is going to be a political
issue actually the the malfeasance was
started perhaps in the previous
administration but it has been going on
apparently on the present administration
now is there any political angle to them
well I don't think we we certainly are
not doing it for political reasons but
however as I have repeatedly said we're
going to let the chips fall where they
may and of course the 608 projects that
you read so much about in the papers ooh
so well happened a hundred percent of
course under the administer the
Democratic administration because the
law was passed at nineteen forty and
expired in fifty i would say that all
the rental properties that are involved
and that is the beginning of it of
course happened prior to Eisenhower
administration now the title one that's
loans for repair purposes for the homes
that has been going on since mr.
Eisenhower took office and I suspect
there's been some irregularities since
that time but you want to remember that
the President of the United States and
mr. Cole the top administrator are the
ones that expose this whole matter and
called it to the attention of the
Congress and the American people and ask
that something be done about it and they
have discharged quite a number of high
government officials Oh Coleman Andrea
says that about 65 and a half million
dollars has been made hay out of and I
was any chance of recollecting that
money I can't answer that that's that's
a matter for the for the courts to
decide it's hard for us at this stage
that say whether whether it can be
collected or not I just don't know so
the K part have either irregularities
been do do you think two basic defects
in the law or too bad and administrators
I think it's been due to both I think
the law was loosely drawn I think it was
bad administration and then I think part
of it is just the good old ingenuity of
the American
and people are the American businessman
to get around the loopholes well senator
Kay part the administration has been
counting as President Eisenhower said on
a booming housing program to keep the
national economy in balance now is this
going to hurt the housing program you
think the scandal this shouldn't hurt it
ought to help it because it ought to get
more what I call call real honesty and
constructive ideas into the housing
business well now the housing bill as I
understand it is in conference has that
bill had taken into account the fact yet
additional Napoli yes the house had
passed the bill before the
irregularities broke we and the Senate
had finished our hearings but we had not
handled the bill in committee and when
they so called scandals broke we held
some hearings primarily with government
officials and we believe that we have
written into the existing law a
sufficient legislation to a stop all the
loopholes and is the new housing program
more liberal and its credit terms does
it make it easier for people to build
home there's any question what the
president houses the housing billet
we're considering at the moment and I
think will become a law within the next
couple of weeks is the most liberal has
ever been offered the American people in
other words the scandal hasn't hurt the
liberality of the program well at that's
correct but have any provision has been
written in to hold you close the
difference between the estimated cost of
building an amount that allowed under
these FHA more have written into the law
that when a builder is finished with his
project that he adds up the total costs
and then certifies that that is the cost
and then
the government only ensures 90 or 80 or
85 or ninety five percent depending upon
what the law is under specific titles
that that amount and we certainly are
going to a stop but what we what we know
and think I was windfall profits where
we're not going to permit that anymore
do you think the Harrigan people don't
want it and I don't think the builders
wanted that is the honest builder I
don't think he wants it illicitly some
dwellers in multiple housing projects
have refused to pay their rent for a
while are they legally in the rights of
do so I don't think they're legally
within their rights and we've heard very
little of that and I think that if we
find that any of them are within their
rights that that ought to be adjusted
peacefully and they ought not to
organize and get excited about the
matter that won't help any Sendek a part
will this housing bill form do you think
an important part of the president's
program will it be an important issue in
the coming campaigns I mean an issue
just to prove that the Republicans are
doing something constructive and and
good well as I said before it's the most
liberal housing bill ever offered the
American people and it ought to go and
will go a long ways towards you
particularly furnishing houses for the
more they they low-income people in the
United States and and we and we have a
new angle in this housing bill that that
will that will eliminate slums in the
future we're trying to avoid the slums
occurring rather than waiting until we
do get a slum condition and clear it up
we're where we in this bill we've
written in some features that if it
works and I think it will work and I
hope it will we're in the future we will
never have slums they will stop them
before they develop in the slums senator
Kay part that now that you're talking
about the work of the present
administration actually now that your
party has the authority and the
responsibility for running the country
how do you still feel that the standby
controls which you were once against and
then favored should be a part of the
national economies in this international
situation guy was ever
against them but I I certainly am in
favor of them and I've always been in
favor of standby controls I I think we
ought to have standby controls giving
the president the United States the
right to impose impose price Wade's and
rent controls the militant emergency
occurs rather than waiting either even
24 hours sooner I think oh I've always
been in favor of that and think that we
ought to have that sort of a law now you
remember I introduced it last year and
tried to get it through but I failed and
i see no chance to do it this year
instead of speaking of the international
situation as a member of the Foreign
Relations Committee you made an
intensive tour of Latin America last
year I guess it was and when you were
down there did you think there was
anything we could do to prevent these
Latin American countries from adopting
extreme political systems well yes I
think what we ought to do is to plea to
pay more attention to Latin America and
I think we ought to cooperate with the
more than we have in the past and I
think we ought to loan the more money on
longer terms and when I say loan more
money I'm not mean I don't necessarily
mean the government i'm talking about
private enterprise i think we ought to
give them longer terms on the things
that we sell them i think we ought to
know more about them and we ought to
encourage them to build up their own
production their own factories in their
own processing of food plants and we
ought to help them to build up
their own industry thereby giving jobs
to their own people well how about our
tariffs are you in favor of reducing
those typical trade bill I think the
tariff is the least end of our this
international trade business I i I'm not
for either extreme high tariffs and I'm
certainly not for free trade but i think
we pay too much attention to the tariff
i think the things we ought to pay more
attention to is long terms and and more
loans and more credit rather than the
tariff because our tariffs in comparison
to other nations are quite low and we do
not have export taxes as they do and
while i think we ought to pay attention
to the tariff so don't think they ought
to be too high nevertheless I I can't
see much good in in throwing 10 million
Americans are 10,000 Americans out of
work in order to give 10,000 people
someplace else jobs I'd rather handle it
on the basis of loaning the money and
helping them to create their own
factories there by having money too so
they can sell and buy among themselves I
want to create more jobs in in in
foreign countries as well as more jobs
here I don't I don't want to handle this
whole business on the basis of throwing
people out of work here in order to give
jobs there are throwing people out of
work there in order to give jobs in this
country I think it can be handled on a
basis of of everybody having a job but
then you feel that as the jobs are built
up and the factories have built up in
the other countries the trade with our
country increases that's right it's not
actually no question about how about
these dollars shortages of these other
countries complain of service well of
course they got dollar shortages I've
always had a dollar short each two
nights where I suspect you have I don't
know anybody in the United States it
hasn't had a dollar short is I've never
had enough dollars they don't have
enough dollars therefore we ought to
give them more credit so to make the
dollars that they do have go farther
that's what we do in the United States
we sell on the Installer the government
do this or should private industry
giveness government possibly can do part
of it but it primarily ought to be done
with with by private industry well thank
you very much senator kay pod for a very
frank discussion well thank you sir the
opinions expressed on the lawn team
Chronos cope
were those of the speakers the editorial
board for this edition of the lawn gene
Cronus go--pause Larry lasseur and
August texture our distinguished guest
was the Honorable Homer ke paas united
states senator from Indiana